foreign
Nathan starts this hour off in South
Dakota hi Nathan welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave and Rachel thank you for taking
that call sure what's up
yeah so I'm a 22 year old farmer and I
recently in an attempt to grow my
operation bought a piece of land
um
so between the land loan and an
operating loan I have about five hundred
thousand dollars in debt
so the land loan is 475
000 and it was just a couple months ago
that I bought that
and it's just starting to set in now
um I'm going to be paying this off for
the next 30 Years and I guess I just
wanted to get your input on what the
best way to tackle that would be
that scares me to death
does it not scare you
it's yes it is
um I mean my chest is tight and I don't
owe the money
yeah wow man you're not freaked out at
all
well I am I mean
Farmland is terribly expensive and it's
always I mean I've always been taught by
my dad and
other Farmers that you just have to
start somewhere and you know start
paying some land down and
so your dad's suggestion is it 22 years
old that you go 500 000 in debt
he endorsed this plan
yes he did wow
okay
I'm not sure I'm not sure that we have
any answers for you to be honest with
you Nathan um well are you going to be
is I guess your plan is to farm the
lands and make an income off of that
correct
yes correct okay what do you anticipate
the income being yeah
well it varies a lot the farm economy
has gotten worse the past few months and
right now it's looking like
the profit from the land won't quite
make the payment so about 25 000 is like
what I think the cross will be off this
year the payment each year is 40 Grand
but on the better years it could make
its own payment possibly
yeah so you bought a business
for five hundred thousand dollars at 22
years old that loses money this year and
on a good year breaks even
well I have other land that I'm renting
from I know did you not hear what I just
said
yes that's just dumb
okay that doesn't make any sense at all
that you know if it you know but because
you're a farmer you think it's okay it's
not okay
that's not that's not good math that's
not good business Farm farming is a
business it should be a profitable
business and the way you engage in it
must be profitable you have to create a
profit and loss statement and you have
to actually create Revenue in excess of
your expenses and you put so much debt
service on yourself you can't breathe
so Nathan the extreme you know
uh decision here would be could you sell
it is there is there a
possibility are there buyers is this why
would you want to work for 30 years for
zero money
all you do is clear a piece of ground 22
and he's a second gen farmer I'm just
saying the logic of this is that by your
dad suggesting this is baffling that
you're going to work for zero profit
for the next 30 Years and your net
result is you clear a piece of ground
yeah yeah it's not logical
I mean I love real estate I love farming
I love Farmers uh but but this doesn't
it's not it doesn't make sense
so something you you guys have to back
up from this a little bit and figure out
a different approach to create a
profitable business or you need to get
out of this before you get foreclosed on
all right because what's going to happen
is if you borrow thirty thousand dollars
to cover your losses this year now
you're 23 and you owe more on the ground
than it's worth
yes that's right and then the next year
we hope to break even
yeah
no
man I'm sorry I don't want to be mean to
you at all I have a tremendous respect
for how hard you work I have tremendous
respect for the fact that a small
percentage of Americans feed all of the
rest of us yes and uh but that does not
mean that because but this is not
sustainable we're not going to justify
it for you Nathan I mean like you want
to be able to sleep at night I want you
to set yourself up I want you if you
told me you're a brain surgeon and you
were breaking even I would tell you not
to be a brain surgeon you know if you
told me you were in brain surgery
believe me if I'm going to get operated
on I'd like a good brain surgeon around
if I want some food on my table I'd like
a good farmer like you out there working
man I appreciate Who You Are
and so I'm All About You winning at this
I want you to be profitable if you told
me you could make a million dollars a
year being a farmer I'd be proud for you
I'd want you to do that okay you know I
mean so this is not me hating on uh but
this idea that just but I got to tell
you man I've worked with Farmers for a
long time 30 years and a lot of them
carry on and gripe about me because I
tell them not to borrow five hundred
thousand dollars on a combine
and and then but there's this
Romanticism with farming that says oh
the math doesn't apply because I'm a
farmer well math does apply it applies
in every dad-com business and it's the
same philosophy we use for any other
business it applies if you're running a
non-profit Church serving Jesus and it
applies if you live in California you
want to buy a house right like oh it is
just the math it's the math and it's
what brings a blessing to your life and
that's our goal here and I wish I had a
magic wand mine's low on batteries that
could make this deal work I don't know
how this deal Works unless you could
tell me you can make a hundred thousand
dollars of your profit instead of losing
money the first year and maybe the
second year and maybe the third year and
ending up owing a hundred thousand
dollars more within a couple of years on
this property than it's worth
and uh that's not a plan so what would
you say sell it that'll rework the
business model I mean if they're I I
don't know how he what he's doing I
don't know what his crop rotation is I
don't know what his particular crop
choice is I I don't know you know what
he's looking at why why you're going
into a business that at 22 that you're
planting that you're planning to lose
money well it could be the CR I mean it
could be the weather I mean the farm
economy and the farm economy depending
on which segment we're talking about is
struggling yeah I don't argue that point
either but you can't just you know you
can't open a restaurant and lose money
yeah the first year in the second year
and oh so much that you can't pay your
payments that's why that doesn't it
doesn't work in any business and man I
wish I could make this better for you I
but you've got to either rework your
business approach to this or you need to
look at getting this sold before you get
yourself bankrupted by your dad's
horrible advice this is the Ramsay show